よーし、さーて
今日も動画頑張るかぁ！
こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーおおおい！
おおおい！
なんだこの提供は！
うおおおい！
もやししゃちょー！
はああああ！
何なんだ一体！？
バカにしてんのか？あああああん？
そう！
この俺は昔から言われ続けた
もやし、もやしと
そして！
つい最近今年からお菓子もやめて
体重はさらに1kg減った
もういいよ！
俺はもやしでいいよ
もういい、もういいよ！
もういい！
俺の事はもやしと呼んでくれても構わない！
だが！
俺自身はもやしではない！
俺はもやしじゃないんだよ...
俺はもやしじゃない
ということで今日は！
僕がね！もやしもやしと言われているので
僕はもうもやしを食えばいいんですよ
僕がもやしをなるべく食ってで
もやしより上の生き物だということを
証明できれば僕はもうもやしではない！
僕がもやし以上の生命体であることが証明される！
もやしを一万本準備しました
わざわざ数えたからね！
よっちが
おもちゃ）ストライーク
よっち）遅い！
よっち）遅いんだ！
よっち）あぁん
200gあたり約500本のもやしが入ってるので
2つで1000本
2000本
3000本
4000本
5000、6000、7000、8000、9000、10000
ということでこちらに今10000本のもやしを準備した
10001本じゃねーわ
もうね、俺がねもやしじゃないってことを証明しますよ
この10000本のもやしを食えなかったら
僕の事はもうもやしと呼んでくれても構わない
ただ！
もし俺がこの10000本食ったらもう俺の事は二度ともやしと呼ぶんじゃねえ
わかったか！！
まじで食うからな
俺今日腹ペコだから！
腹ペコの俺ならなんでも食rrrrrrr
じゃぁ行くぞ！
10000本チャレンジ！
スタート！
ルールは簡単！
もやしをとりあえず10000本食べれば俺の勝ち
食えばOK！
簡単だろ？
いただきます
うん
普通
はっはっ
もう5本も食っちまったぜ！
余裕だぜ
うん
おいしい！
全然行ける気がします
ちょっと飽きちゃった
オラァ
はっはっは！
さぁさぁディップしちまうぜえ！
フウ！イエー！
あっ、うま
あれ、待って
えっ、待って
俺水洗いしてなくね？
待って水洗い
えっ、水洗いしなきゃいけない？
水洗いは？
水洗いしなくていいのかなぁ？
まいっか！
これが
彼の最後の言葉となった
ふっ
俺は負けねえぞ
ふー
もやしだけだときつい！
少しでも食べやすいようにハムを買ってきました
少しでもいいからちょっと味を味を変えたい
はー
うん
うんYO！
オーエ
すいませんでしたー！
非常に苦しいです
腹がパンパン
水気が多いからなんか水分的に腹がいっぱいになるパターンだった
半分はたぶん食べてると思うんで高さ的には
もういいです
僕の負けです
俺の事は
もやしと呼んでくれ！
ぶっちゃけ食べれると思ったんですけどちょっと数の暴力
もやし炒めとかにして食べようと思います
というわけでお知らせです！
僕が
もやしになるゲームが出ます
どんなゲームかといいますと
僕がもやしになるゲームです
操作とかはすごい簡単で楽なんですけども
実は！奥深いゲームらしくて
特別なね隠しもやしみたいなのもいるんですけども
なんかねこう特別なギミックを使って
スマホを傾けたりしないと出てこないみたいなもやしもいるらしくて
地味に奥深いゲームでございます
このゲームなんですけどもえっと、
まだリリースされてなくて事前に予約することができます
で！
その予約数によってゲームの内容が変わってくるらしいです
なのでみなさんが予約すれば予約するほど
ゲームは更に進化する
まぁなんだろうなぁ
ひょっとしたらアゴの妖精とかも
出るかもね！
おっと、誰とは言わないよ
もしよかったらみなさん予約してみてください
はぁ、ついに公認でもやしだよ
もやしは後輩呼んでなんか炒めて食います
じゃあな！